when taylor swift called and said i'm
doing a song
about i'm doing a song and all the
characters in it are named after your
kids was your first question like
hold on what is this song about
what exactly are they doing in this song
yeah i mean you know this the yeah the
the names are the names of our kids but
you know we trust her implicitly and you
know she's she's
very sensitive to any of that stuff ryan
reynolds talking about taylor swift
using his and blake lively's daughter's
names in her song betty betty i won't
make assumptions about why you switched
your homeroom but i think it's cause of
me
and i was actually really grateful for
that the song which was released on
taylor's 2020 folklore album also
features the names inez and james
you heard the rumors from me next you
can't believe a word she says most times
[Music]
obviously the song is has nothing to do
with our kids other than our kids names
uh but i mean what a
what a what an honor i don't know we
thought it was pretty pretty damn
amazing we were we still do you know i
still wanna wander down the street and
shake my head thinking i can't believe
that happened ryan says his kids had no
idea about the special song lyrics at
first we surprised them with it yeah
they they didn't know they had no idea
so we don't tell them they must have
died i find they're they're they're most
compliant if you offer them no access to
outside information in the serious xm
interview with jess kegel ryan also
talks about being a girl dad to his
three little ones i don't even think of
it as like i'm a girl dad like you know
i i just like i love my kids i you know
i i
want them to grow up to be self-aware
human beings that you know are
affect some positive change somehow some
way in the world earlier this week e.t
caught up with ryan while he promoted
his new movie free guy he couldn't stop
gushing about wife blake just weeks
ahead of their september wedding
anniversary which marks nine years of
marriage well you know i i'm lucky i'm
married to my best friend you know
that's that's the hope we all have you
know it's so you're you just you're
lucky to partner up with someone that
you you want to spend every second with
and i'm very lucky to have that